تونس الخضراء مهدده بالعطش حديث الناس
والاعلام والسوشي الميديا في بلد لم يتعود
من قبل على الجفاف تنام سواحل في احضان
المتوسط وتنبع عيونه باجود انواع المياه
الجوفيه اما للشرب او للعلاج اصبح اليوم
بلا ادنى شك قاب قوسين من الضما
[موسيقى]
بلغ معدل امتلاء السدود العام
28.5 فقط الى حدود اواخر ديسمبر من العام
الماضي في مؤشر خطير على وضعيه الموارد
المائيه في تونس بفعل الجفاف خاصه في
منطقه الوسط بحسب احصائيه رسميه
ارقام تدقون قوس الخطر وتشغل الشارع
التونسيه الذي لا زال يتذكر جيدا السيف
القائد الذي شهدته البلاد خلال سنه
الماضيه تم تسجيل درجات حراره قياسيه
تواصلت حتى اشهر الخريف تلاها انحباس
المتوسط في الامطار متى جاي على الفلاح
سبق وان حضر تقارير دوليه من شح المياه
واثاره الخطيره على تونس اليوم تتسرب
معلومات حول امكانيه لجوء الحكومه الى
اعتماد نظام التقسيط المائي لاول مره في
تاريخ البلاد كاحد الحلول التي تحذر منظمه
ونشطاء في مجال المياه من اعتمادها فهل
ستمضي السلطات فعلا في هذا الاجرام الى
صباح العربيه احلام العبدلي تونس